well here we are in sri sri rec center
and our sri rec center at the farmers
market as part of a partnership between
the government the Ministry of Health
and the BC Association of farmers
markets where we are going to provide
even more opportunity for BC families BC
seniors to have access to the freshest
tastiest
fruit produce grown anywhere in the
world BC homegrown produce coupon books
that will be made available through our
partnerships for families to come to
farmers markets like this across British
Columbia we give them to low-income
families pregnant women and seniors who
are participating in skill building
programs like canning and learning about
nutrition and cooking and then they use
these coupons and they take them to the
farmers market we're having it in 21
communities this year and because we
received 2 million dollars it's going to
ramp up considerably next year and then
the next year even more so we'll be
really in a lot of communities as the
years go on right this is a fantastic
program it will help most some of our
clients to be able to connect to the
farmers market those are be the
individuals and families may otherwise
not have the opportunity to come and
shop here and then get connect to the
farmers and connect to the land and to
the food so it's very exciting a lot of
people are looking forward to it it's a
great initiative way to further promote
BC produce and healthy living healthy
diets